tous les voyants sont enfin ouverts
après plus de neuf ans de discussions et
de recours la ville de maurepas va
accueillir un multiplexe en 2019 en face
du village des loisirs
la signature officielle entre les
exploitants et effectué ce jeudi 7
décembre
un soulagement pour la mairie c'est un
projet de cinéma qui est très attendu
très très attendu par les commerçants
moi qui vais les voir régulièrement
parce qu'ils sont en attente de ce
cinéma pour leur permettre de même de se
diversifier de s'agrandir ou même
d'investir et de créer de nouveaux
emplois
donc je suis vraiment totalement
satisfait ça va voilà dynamiser la ville
de maurepas le secteur et fait rayonner
notre belle ville au delà même de mort
par le cinéma proposera notamment des
blockbusters américains et des grands
films français il sera équipé de huit
salles et plus de 1700 fauteuil
coût total de l'opération 13 millions
d'euros là comme on veut mettre toutes
les dernières technologies
le numérique bien sûr leçon atmos et
projecteur laser est comme il est éco
responsable et coûte un petit peu plus
cher mais en gros faut savoir
aujourd'hui un multiplex sur un
multiplexe
c'est un million d'euros la salle layana
8 savait pas eu 8 millions parce que
justement on veut faire quelque chose
d'un peu différent
les premiers coups de pioche seront
donnés au mois d'avril prochain les
exploitants espère attirer entre 450
mille cinq cent mille spectateurs par an